what's that you didn't think I could
think of ten more things think again
welcome to what is almost definitely the
last episode of 10 things you didn't
know about Dark Souls as usual here are
the rules I'm going to tell you 10
little-known but interesting facts if
you knew everything then leave a dislike
if you learned something new then reward
me with a like let's get started number
one equip the orange chard ring when you
kick an enemy you'll do a small amount
of fire damage number two use alloys
talisman on a woken up minik and you'll
put it back to sleep there's a very high
chance that it'll drop the headpiece and
it will definitely drop the item hidden
inside number 3 is also related to
mimics any enemies grab attack can be
escaped earlier by mashing the bumpers
on your controller you'll notice I take
less damage when I do this next is
number 4 and I think I'm going to get a
lot of you with this one use gold pine
resin in the Crystal Caves and it will
come out blue instead it stays blue even
if you leave like wise apply it outside
and walk into the caves and it will stay
gold it's weird number 5 the egghead
mechanic the egg burdened can infect you
with a parasite after a while you'll
scratch your head and 5 minutes later
you'll become egg burdened yourself but
did you know that the egg consumes half
your souls if you feed it a hundred
thousand souls then it will evolve into
a larger form with a fully grown
parasite this animation will replace
your kick animation doing a bit of
damage while knocking them back and for
number 6 have you ever realized how
useful the spell oral decoy is it can be
used to expose the weaknesses of many
enemies like the giant Knights it's
actually surprisingly useful if you're
having trouble with the Capra demon
since he'll focus on it at the expense
of all else number 7
doesn't really need an explanation
number 8 isn't something a sane person
would try if you damage the annal Wando
bad wing demon it will fly away the same
goes for the crow at filing shrine
except the bad wing demon returns the
crow will not all right we're up to
number 9 and I'm kind of wondering how
many people knew everything at this
point did you know that there's a short
alternate cutscene for gwyndolin if you
enter as a white phantom it's strange
that they even bothered but it's there
and here it is number 10 it's
technically three things but let's group
them under the title rare boss moves did
you know that Neto has a gravattack I
waited 20 minutes
for him to do it but it does a ton of
damage at least now you know that you
have to match those bumpers if you want
to get out early
the second rare boss move I chose is the
bed of chaos she has this fireball
attack when you're at a distance she did
it instantly here for me but I could
never get her to repeat it and lastly
the moonlight butterfly will sometimes
shoot a blue orb when she swapped sides
on the bridge this particularly happens
when she's low on health so did you know
everything let me know if you want to
try and see how many things you new out
of 50 then click on the screen for the
playlist and watch all five videos I'd
also like to take the chance to thank
you guys for watching my videos I really
liked making them but reading your
comments and interacting with you all is
the best part of this thanks for
sticking around I'm looking to make the
most of your viewership I want to put
more time more effort and more money
into this I'm not going to turn into a
let's play channel I'm not going to make
short clickbait videos I I just want to
give you something that you genuinely
look forward to clicking every week I
expect you'll get a better idea of what
I'm talking about by the end of the year
there's some cool stuff in the works
thanks for subscribing and thanks for
being a part of this I'll see you next
time
you